what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg john how are you i'm
great how are you i
am okay
you look great that's what i like to
hear pushing through and what you guys
can push through to do is what can they
do with this thumb oh they can put it up
they can leave a like
this is called back and forth learn how
to do it
the key to chemistry on camera this is
cheering each other's questions hey
all right guys we got two pieces of
marvel to talk about that marvel train
does not stop rolling in after this
weekend so much marvel for the next
couple years so much breaking news so
much information so much so that we're
gonna be a day late to it just like
today we gotta talk about some x-men
updates some major x-men updates and we
gotta talk about a major avengers
kang
dynasty update as well two things i'm
sure you've already heard about but if
you haven't stick around and if you
already have who knows we might say
something that's slightly different or
more of the same that everyone else has
said
that's where you got to stick around to
find out x-men so here's the main update
there's this report that's been going
around that you could hear more details
about but the basic summary goes like
this whoever played a character within
the fox x-men universe no one can
contractually replace that actor that
character until 2025 or after so you
know take ty sheridan everyone's
favorite cyclops everyone's like yeah
that's my cyclops no one can replace
thai sheridan never right now but that
also explains why you can get like
patrick stewart at least to cameo as
professor x and multiverse of madness
evan peters to not quite be quicksilver
but sort of probably because of all
these rights but then it makes you
question like maybe that's why they had
kamala khan changed to be a spoiler a
mutant versus
an inhuman now it's making me really
believe the theories that have been
going around about how you know they
they're probably going to be gearing up
to do a mutants movie first before they
actually do an x-men movie like they
very well could just wait until 2025 or
after because it's kind of making me
ponder is this why they're churning out
so many properties over the next couple
years so they can really finally do
x-men the way how everyone's been
demanding and wanting i say that and the
other part of me goes well they could
just you know spread out their
properties a little bit more and just
weave the x-men in between but they got
a specific plan they got to adhere by so
i don't know what the reasoning might be
but that doesn't mean that we wouldn't
be able to possibly still see some fox
x-men characters within something like
avengers secret wars this is the
multiverse saga after all is it not
humphrey it is officially as of this
weekend so with it being the multiverse
saga you could very well have some cool
cameos in something like secret wars or
even king dynasty where characters come
together former ones hugh jackman 65
years old because he will have aged 20
years in the next two
yep and
or one of the other x-men characters so
that way you do have the ultimate
collision of all these characters so you
still get some mutants and you know this
news might bum people out because they
gotta wait a little bit longer to hear
something truly official however the
mutants universe is so massive and
that's been one of the biggest things to
theorize and why a lot of people have
thought they're just gonna smash
together some universes because of the
fact of how vast and how much it would
change the world to have mutants within
it i'm like well you got a bunch of
other characters you can pull from to
make a mutant's movie without having to
pull from the fox x-men ones and that
way it's even more rewarding when the
patience pays off by the time you get to
2026 where it's just two straight years
of x-men
well that's what i was thinking because
at first you see phase six there's so
many open slots and some of them are in
2025 and you're like oh that's where the
mutants are going but they say you know
probably they can't even use or shoot
anything even in advance until after
that window is over so i almost feel
like yeah you could pay homage to the
classic 20th century x-men roster then
after your big secret wars event you can
close that universe out officially
finally send off any last threads that
need it or deserve it and then you can
start fresh with a really sort of x-men
centric phase seven yeah give sophie
turner one last shot at being a dark
phoenix one more dark phoenix some more
dark phoenix thrown in there yeah that's
the updates of that wanted to be a
little more patient they got a lot of
properties
right now there's always a conversation
of quantity over quality with marvel i
definitely think you know let them
handle their projects and then we'll get
our x-men and we'll be happy the next
one uh won't take as long to explain but
it is exciting you know we were talking
in our live stream about you know who
might the directors possibly be for
avengers king dynasty and avengers
secret wars easy to theorize that
whoever they got for kang dynasty would
do secret wars now did they confirm that
this individual would be the one who
would do secret wars as well or is it
only being reported for king dinosaur
believe it's only killing the only
report i've seen is specifically kang
dynasty right now so who's being
reported right now and we saw this on
the hollywood reporter to be directing
avengers kang dynasty we had been
theorizing this is not one of the names
we threw out there but we were
speculating that it would be a director
who's helmed one of these movies from
phase four through phase six they would
go you know what they're doing they knew
how to do the movie like the way they
did with russo brothers and then let's
have them direct it and we're going to
be getting
chloe's
to finish each other's sentences yeah
yeah dustin daniel [ __ ]
this destin daniel creden who i think
did an incredible job when i was
thinking about the movies that we've
gotten so far within the mcu that has
one of the better ensemble films like
the whole ensemble really shines
protagonist antagonists some side
characters here they're like the world
was truly fleshed out and they
introduced so many new people in such a
new world i think destin daniel credit
really nailed it like it's not one of my
favorite mcu films that has some of my
favorite action out of the mcu and
there's a lot of things that i would
consider like favorite qualities of the
mcu however i think for a first film and
then to introduce so many things versus
what the russo brothers did which was
carrying on a character who was already
introduced in two prior movies i think
he did an excellent job i think what he
displayed there definitely shows yeah i
think he can pull off an avengers level
movie for sure especially with what he
did with scale action cast and then he
wouldn't have to the worry of having to
introduce a bunch of new people either
he can literally work with the machine
who knows maybe he'll get fired to
replace that you know how these things
go as far as it goes i think he's a
solid solid pick it would be interesting
if they got one director for dynasty and
then different director for a secret
wars yeah i think that could be actually
a really cool collaborative thing where
yeah it's like clearly this installment
is by this director but clearly they
also coordinated it could easily work
out that he does both but i almost
wonder if they're going to film them
simultaneously or something and have
basically two units running yeah it's
not the name i threw out and i wish i
had because thinking back it's the movie
i think of when i go that movie had so
much to do chongqi it had so much to
introduce it has so much to juggle and
manage while still telling something of
an emotionally resonant and impactful
story yeah and i feel like with the
amount of world building and balancing
that movie is like cranked to the
extreme in terms of the economics of
time and pacing but i feel like of all
the movies i've seen thus far in phase
four that is the one i point to and i'm
like for what they had to cram into that
amount of time that's like about the
smoothest i could imagine it being given
the circumstances and so yeah he seems
like a really solid choice on all fronts
managing the immense chaos but also
bringing some of that emotional weight
because you know there's gonna be some
heavier stuff coming especially as we
get into phase six and i think that's a
perfect territory for him one problem
with it he's not white
you know
that's the man i don't know if he can
really handle it you know because we've
had three white people helm the other
avengers movies and i just think you
know
you you don't want to fix let's get
peyton read let's just stay safe and get
peyton reed to direct both of the ends
of the don't try to fix what ain't
broken you know that's just what i'm
saying that's what i'm saying i feel
like there's a strong correlation
between it white marvel white marvel all
the way
um anyway guys
what do you think about them getting an
asian guy to direct avengers gang
half those characters aren't asian like
why would they need his i don't
understand this doesn't make sense
does it make sense
we riot
no not my
not my kang did you get the point what
do you what do you guys think about this
x-men news is it a bummer to you what do
you guys think about destin daniel crown
do you think he's the right pick for
avengers king dynasty leave your
thoughts down below please do subscribe
click that notification bell leave a
like and hey let's end this with a
jean jeter it's another comican but even
more than that my friend your birthday
is coming up my dude so i thought who
better to shout out on a comic-con video
is it wakanda forever maybe i don't know
yet i don't know it's coming out man but
i do know that you are a mensch and i'm
glad that you're here with us and uh hey
leave me uh you know a charming voice
message in your inbox
and uh keep doing what you do i'm
looking forward uh you know to the next
real rejects cringe laugh compilation
quantomania station
what a marvel it will be puns
puns love you buddy be well